on
tente d'aller plus loin avec vous bruno
daroux bonjour brno bonjour les abers
s'intéresse évidemment au chaos sort de
ses bureaux de nièces qu'un cette ville
stratégique de l'est ville présentée
comme comme clé les russes disent avoir
pris la majeure partie de cette localité
érigée à présent vers le centre en quoi
la prise de cette ville qui s'annonce
longue serait telle stratégique pour
moscou et bien effectivement ce serait
stratégique dans la mesure pour les
ruches ou une fois cette ville prise en
fait il pourrait plus facilement
contrôler les zones du dombass encore
voilà sous leur contrôle en fait vous
voyez ces voix là c'est ce ce seront là
où on voit très bien c'est vers donetsk
est licite gens qu à côté d'ailleurs ils
ont besoin de contrôler cette ville pour
pouvoir conquérir toute cette partie qui
leur manque et qui viendrait parachever
leur contrôle du dombass donc c'est
important d'un point de vue stratégique
c'est important aussi pour l'avenir
poutine pour l'affichage de la conduite
de la guerre car je vous rappelle que
c'est la deuxième stratégie russe après
la première qui a un peu lamentablement
échoué il s'agissait d'envahir tous
azimuts le pays pour conquérir tout le
territoire ukrainien la deuxième
stratégie c'est se concentrer sur l'est
donc il faut absolument que ça marche
d'où cette obsession russe sur ce
bordeaux niet et de fait les russes
progress vers le centre de la ville le
président heynckes qui lui même
reconnaît que les combats sont très
difficiles pour les soldats l'ukrainien
regarder ça c'était l'un de ses derniers
tweets sur le sujet alors néanmoins
selon les renseignements américains qui
sont cités par nos confrères du new york
times tout ne se passe pas très bien
pour les russes il ya décidément une
question de mauvaise organisation de
mauvaises logistique une question de
motivation peu élevé chez les
combattants russes aient eu beaucoup de
pertes depuis la fin février les
services américains pointent notamment
le comportement extrêmement prudent des
pilotes russes qui bombardent les
territoires de l'est
aignan et qui en suis trop vieux
retourne tout de suite au-dessus du sol
de la fédération de russie ce qui fait
qu est ce qui fait que l'aviation russe
n'a pas le contrôle de la maîtrise du
ciel ukrainien alors que ce serait
possible et le nouvel homme fort de
l'armée russe le général alexander
dvornikov qu'on présentait comme un peu
le grand manitou qui allait justement
permettre à cette deuxième phase de la
stratégie de réussir et bien ce général
wernick au fond ne l'a pas vu depuis
deux semaines les ukrainiens qui accuse
les russes de crimes de guerre
aujourd'hui moscou qui serait prête à
tout pour arriver à ses fins selon la
procureur général de kiev plusieurs
milliers de crimes de guerre présumés
auraient été commis nos wii et selon la
procureure on serait au tour de quinze
mille cas de crimes de guerre présumés
alors les soupçons craignant pas
simplement c'est un procureur qui le dit
mais évidemment on va rester prudent les
soupçons ukrainien en fait porte sur des
transfert sous la contrainte de
personnes ukrainienne vers plusieurs
régions de russie soupçons de torture de
meurtres de civils de destructions
volontaires d'infrastructures civiles
alors dans cette affaire l'ukraine peut
compter sur le soutien de la cpi la cour
pénale internationale et sur le soutien
de plusieurs pays occidentaux dont la
france d'ailleurs qui a par exemple
envoyé des équipes de gendarmerie pour
aider au recueil de preuves rapide sur
le terrain de ces crimes de guerre ça ça
a été fait par exemple à abuja pour
permettre ensuite à la justice et à la
cpi de lancer des procédures contre les
soldats et responsables russes qui sont
impliqués dans ces crimes de guerre
l'enjeu en fait pour la justice
ukrainienne d'un jeu compliqué c'est
d'aller à la fois vite et lentement
d'aller vite pour recueillir les
témoignages et les preuves de crimes de
guerre medal est aussi assez lentement
pour ne pas organiser des procès
expéditifs cents observateurs
internationaux pour rester en fait dans
l'état de droit et éviter de se
retrouver pointé du doigt par moscou qui
seraient trop content de l'occasion un
équilibre vous le voyez difficile mais
indispensable pour que ces crimes soit
un jour puni avec une véritable merci
beaucoup pour le décryptage